[Musik]
es war wie ein Schlachtfeld, also sagte
ich mir, diese sehr geringe Chance, dass einige
von ihnen am Leben sind
[Musik]
in der Reisetasche ist diese
Ventilationsenergie in Richtung Jahr zur Löschung unkritisches Khaman
Dhokla, das ich senden werde, ist eine schlechte Ganga,
die ich brauche  Ich bin für die Houdini
Edevalla Ferguson van Fiat Singh
Chouhan Ganga in einem Installationsgarten Amamiya
Details durch Taguchi Avedon zurück und
nur aus Wut Latisha machen - Asche nicht
Akutan bellende Hunde runter Ich habe eine
Person unseres Shops
hieronymus Circuity Builder eingeladen, die
anwesend ist  anima yamaneika löse es Stein
nicht Amerika schickte für Uterus Wahrheit 10 mir
bist zufällige Zone sie nicht irischer Elch eine
äußere Hülle Duralglühen für direkte Kraft
in Unentschlossenheit Grabber, um Oxy
[Musik]
Stil zurück Alpha zu schaffen - ich sehe, sie schlagen zu -
und in Käse Gators  Gehen Sie oft am
Flughafen Dallas Karriere - Kaval Ticket Dozent
sicher, Sie schwitzen und schützen Sie sich vor
Schneiders Lassen Sie uns Erfinder
Dannan stoppen für die Michael strengste
Objektivität Fudo Assad sprechen für Brot
musica moderat  Die depressive OD-Antwort
Levine ist es Watson Eluga Propanol-
Fetisch mit ihm war eine Zusammenfassung der Mutation,
die für Allan Slater Homöopathie für
das Hotel atif couid Objekt
[Musik] macht,
verweigert, da dies zu einer
Behauptung führt, dass der Titel der verlassenen Eden-Taktik
als Unterströmung geschrieben wird
Asche täglich in einer Ausrottung
fiel der Orientierungslauf noch auf Simpers Onan
zeigen versklavte ruhige
Täler von Sternen über Welle hatte keine
Freundlichkeit zu Geburtstrauma aus der Legende und
MP braucht unsere Ola III auf jedem dummen Paar
Ich bin Aandrah Norma Benton Büro
in einer Gruppe  von liberal eine Hypothek eine
Einrichtung links Sonnenschlaf Toots Volley
solche Gedanken von allen gehackt die
Gedanken teilen Toots Bösewichte eine Gruppe
mit der besten
Zaida supa GAO indisches Schnäppchen ja
offensichtliches Hinterfeld, wir umarmen uns wahrscheinlich
zusammen sein mobiler Spargel piep a - Klaue
Oh Taylor Taylor Taylor  Isaac, der Film
Newman war hart, handelte von einer Gruppe, viel
über Gesundheit. Sorkin ist hier, nur Kinder,
Kinder kennen mich wirklich, dachte
[Musik]
fr  om ein fisch lieber oben buddhistischer abnehmen
glukose hirsch gericht ich kann auf ein
thema klicken zementmischer wasserfilter reha-manager permanenter khmer cosmoderm der in einer drüse auf dem rücksitz geholfen hat
lass sie
jetzt greifen kovacs allah ist das management
involviert für die nicht zu schlau ist
Amerika und dies ist Clark, siehe
das Portal Avas Wohnung in der
Lage, Gott in englischer Lyrik
in Südafrika MCC zu hoffen, wenn der Schmutz so
exponentiell auflagert, um in
diesem Moment eine obdachlose Larve zu lagern - um Englisch
mit Kegeln, Kegeln, unterirdischen Felsen aus
dieser mysteriösen Luft zu sprechen  Knurren einige CC-
Buchhandlungen ängstlich in die Stirn für das
andere Lambda.
Mein Name ist Tomas Batali.
Ich bin dieses Jahr gerade 50 geworden und ich bin
Architekt und wir waren dabei, die Oh Wahrheit zu tun,
wir wussten, dass das schlechte Wetter
kommen würde wir haben es getan  Ich weiß nicht, wie schlimm es war, aber
wir wussten es, also haben wir es geschafft, die ersten
drei Tage auf ideale Weise zu machen, ja, und
dann kam das Wort schlechtes Wetter
und alles, ich meine, alles ging
schief von Jus  Es könnte nicht schlimmer werden als
das
[Musik]
Betty, es war meine beste Freundin in Boston. Oh,
ich war die ganze Zeit König mit dem
Tourplan, auch dem normalen Plan, wir gingen viele
Male zusammen, und dann sagte sie, na
ja, ich sagte, Matt, die Idee war von mir  Warum
machen wir dieses Jahr nicht die ganze Wahrheit, wir
waren beide frei, also lasst es uns tun, und sie
sagte, oh, das ist großartig, ich wollte
es immer mein ganzes Leben lang tun, weil mein Vater es getan hat.
Ich glaube, sie hat es in der Vergangenheit 11 Mal
getan  Ihr Vater war ein Experte für die ganze
Wahrheit, mit der wir uns verabreden sollten, diese Reise
heißt Serpentine, also ist Ihr Arm wie
vielleicht drei Stunden Kunde, es gibt einen
Sattel, den Sie mit Skiern hinunterfahren, und das Besondere an
dieser Reise, und deshalb müssen Sie es auf keinen Fall
tun  bei schlechtem Wetter ist
das so und ich lerne es danach, weil ich
nichts wusste, ich meine, ich habe mich nicht
informiert, weil ich mit einem Führer war,
was immer noch ein Fehler ist, weil man
immer wissen muss, wohin man gehen muss
, muss man Karten haben  und so, aber an einem anderen Tag
weißt du, wenn du einen Führer hast, bist du
faul  y also vertraust du ihm einfach, es ist ein
Fehler, aber das ist nicht
nur mir, sondern uns allen passiert, also im Grunde
diese Reise den Sattel hinauf, hinunter Skifahren
und dann gibt es eine erzwungene Passage
zwischen zwei Felsen von zwei Metern Breite, also
musst du  kommen Sie durch das, wie man Engpass sagt,
und danach sind diese
langen Traversen, aber einfach, und dann holen
Sie sich bei den Lebenden auf, aber
am Morgen hat der Führer beschlossen, zu gehen,
niemand sagt etwas darüber, was
für mich ziemlich beunruhigend ist
Weil wir wussten, dass das Wetter
kommen würde, ging ich zu dem Führer
dort und sagte, was wir hier machen würden.
Er sagte, wir fangen an und wenn Sie schlechtes
Wetter sehen, kommen wir zurück.
Ich war der Plan, aber an diesem Morgen haben wir gerade erst
angefangen, wissen Sie  weil er gegangen ist, haben wir uns verstanden
und dann sind wir hier ein
paar Stunden geklettert und wir befinden uns in einem
Whiteout, was ein Zustand ist, in dem
man zwei Meter entfernt nicht sehen kann, also ist es ziemlich
schlimm,
und dann weißt du, dass wir uns verlaufen haben und wir haben
den ganzen Tag
den Kerl verloren  hatte ein Handy mit den Karten, die
er für eine Weile benutzte, und dann, glaube ich, war
er eingefroren, also bin ich gegangen
Deshalb biete ich mein GPS an und ich kann es zeigen, also haben
wir dasselbe GPS dann den ganzen
Tag benutzt.
Ich habe auf das GPS geschaut und der Typ
war in der Gruppe. So haben wir
das letzte Stück zum Sattel gemacht, also sind wir
losgefahren  Richtung Herz, aber wir haben die
ganze Zeit Steine gefunden, also konnt
n wir nicht in diese Passage kommen, durch die wir hier runte
wollten, und hier ereig
ete sich die Tragödie, weil wir wegen
dieser Felsensache hier nicht durchkommen konnten, du ke
nst die Passage I  war optimistisch,
weil ich meine, deshalb habe ich nie
die Kontrolle verloren, weil es zeigte, dass
wir sehr nah dran waren. Wir waren auf einer
geraden Linie.
Wir waren wahrscheinlich 500 Meter sehr nah dran,
also sagte mein Gott, ich habe ein paar Emini gesehen,
die wie ein Stein sind  Türme, also versuchen wir
, dorthin zu gelangen, aber um dorthin zu gelangen, wa  Es ist
ein sehr schlechter Aufstieg, also sind alle Leute
erschöpft, aber wir haben es geschafft,
und er hat entschieden, dass wir dort bleiben,
wir werden hier ein Loch graben, was
völlig unmöglich war, weil es keinen
Schnee gab, es war wie ein Sattel, unser felsiger
Sattel, so was  Ich habe so viel wie
möglich unter dem Felsen gegraben, und das haben
wir eine Weile getan, aber weil es so
windig war, hatte es keinen Sinn. Ich meine, wenn Sie
ein Loch graben,
gibt es keinen Weg hinein, deshalb haben Sie
überlebt, aber mit dem Wind  Schlag,
du wirst sterben. Ich hatte Glück, nicht. Ich
meine, es war offensichtlich, dass wir alle
dort
in diesem Zustand starben.
Betty war erschöpft, als das Messer
anfing, rief sie meinen Namen
, als hätte sie meinen Namen so
oft gerufen  wie hat mir geholfen oder so was und ich
sagte schau das einzige was du
nicht einschlafen musst ja also hab ich es geschossen
schau du musst dich bewegen du musst planen dich
zu bewegen in 8 stunden ich hätte ich
hätte geduscht - Betty - einfach  wach bleiben,
aber ich konnte nicht viel tun, ich drehte sie zwei
oder drei um  Manchmal, weil sie
mit dem Gesicht nach unten in den Schnee ging,
weiß ich nicht warum, und ich war frei, aber
ich konnte nicht viel tun, weil ich diesen Film machen musste,
weißt du, das ist die
minimale Bewegung, die du machen kannst  Um
am Leben zu bleiben, kann es nicht viel tun
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und vielleicht habe ich während der Bewegung geschlafen.
Ich weiß es nicht, denn eine Sache
, an die ich mich erinnere, ist, dass ich
Francesca neben mir hatte, nicht Julie, ich hatte
Francesca  und ich umarmte sie an den Haaren,
ich hängte sie auf und sie umarmte mich,
als ob wir ein Liebespaar wären, weißt du,
und dann ich, ich weiß nicht, dass etwas
in Francesca passiert ist, war Julia,
ich meine Francesca, und
irgendwann wurde mir klar, dass sie es war  Nicht mehr Francesca,
was war Julia,
also war Franciscan einfach da und sie
war von Schnee bedeckt und da war Julia, also
weiß ich nicht, was passiert ist, aber ich habe nicht
realisiert, dass es wahrscheinlich passiert ist, dass
Francesca irgendwie nicht
gegangen ist  wirklich weg ich weiß nicht wann
sie nur ein paar Meter entfernt war und ich
Julia wi hatte  Ich weiß nicht, das war in
der Bourne und dann morgens
öffnen wir unsere Augen, dann waren wir vorsichtig und
dann entdeckte sie diese Gruppe von Skifahrern direkt
darunter. Ich ging mit meinen letzten
Kräften dorthin und ich fange an zu schreien und sie
sahen mich  und dann ging ich zurück, wartete und
nach ungefähr 15 Minuten kamen Menschenretter
um das Lager und dann kam der Hubschrauber
und es war wie auf einem Schlachtfeld und sie
waren alle mit Schnee bedeckt, also sagte
ich mir, diese sehr geringe Chance, dass einige
von ihnen leben  und ich war mir auch nicht sicher
, ob Betty gestorben ist, also hoffte ich immer noch, dass
sie weißt, dass sie
lebend mit einer Körpertemperatur von drei
Grad im Krankenhaus ankam. Jesus, dort starb sie
[Musik]
und die letzten zwei Monate waren hart
Ich könnte jetzt nicht schlafen, es wird
besser, aber ich fühlte mich, als wäre ich
in vielen Dingen schwach strukturiert und auch wütend. Ich
meine, besonders, ich meine, ich liebe Betty, also war
es für mich eine wichtige Person, die so
emotional gebraucht wurde, auch für mich, weil ich '
Ich bin auch sauer auf mich, weil y  Du weißt, diese
Dinge haben mein Leben verändert, also ist es schwer,
aber du weißt, es ist nicht mehr dasselbe wie
vorher, aber jetzt will ich wirklich
kämpfen  'Das ist waha sah eine leibliche Mutter
ohne tercio de Mouton oder Hunnam
Erbe 58 Prozent Alkohol macht
für Abwechslung die physische Gemeinschaft Araber
schaffen den Boden, um sie zu kennen eine
Partnerin des inneren Friedens
Ich hoffe, sie für die Partnerin für die Jugend
wird unter dem relativen Namen leiden  Kein Fisch,
all die Rechnungen, die so für ein Bier gebaut wurden -
Philippe, die Gesundheit und das Ende dieses
Biergeschäfts, arbeitete Mila Bakr, um den Glitchman zu verteidigen, der
traditionell konzipiert wurde
Entwickle dein Design
Alexei
[Musik]